so this is a design mock that was just
given to me by a designer the left pane
here is just information on colors so
you can just ignore it for now now we
just finished talking about boxes and
boxes and how fun it is to draw boxes
around things so when you see a page
like this we need to start looking at it
and think how do I draw a box around
every visual element here and then how
do I do it until I'm down to a very
simple element like a single image or
paragraph well the best way to learn how
is to actually do it
I'll get you started by drawing the
first three first will have a box around
this header here now inside this box I
see two other boxes one around our image
here and another around our name and
title over here now it's your turn to
draw the rest of the boxes around the
remaining element a link to the mock is
included for you in instructor notes now
don't worry I'm not going anywhere when
you're done please let me know how you
completed this task and how many boxes
you ended up using to divide the page
now when you box off' i'd this design
and yes that's a technical term box by
did you save an image of the design and
draw boxes with the graphics program did
you just draw the boxes separately on a
piece of paper did you print out the
page and draw on it or did you print out
the page and cut it up with scissors and
don't forget to let me know how many
boxes you found on the page